time now for our 2020 roundup first up
if you thought
bernie was a little off his rocker
before wait until you hear
this sanders is promising to reveal
information about aliens
if he wins the white house watch if you
got
into the office and you found out
something about aliens
if you found out something about ufos
would you let us know
well i'll tell you my wife would demand
that i let you know
is your wife at ufo not no she's not a
ufo though which is bernie what is
going on do you have any access to
records and you don't have any access
i don't honestly i don't know okay you
let us know though all right i'll be on
the show we'll announce it on the show
please so dana he's apparently smoking
right you see him
i don't know because i've never smoked
it and i don't know what it's like
but you only do the edibles right i
would say that this seems like
bribery yes just because you're trying
to bribe
for votes right because people want this
information so bad he's like i'll do it
and then you probably won't because the
cia will stop there are ufos they're
living in bernie's hair
they're really really micro microscopic
by the way every pres
every candidate does do this they say
this but then once they see the files
their brains are erased but
i think it was a 22 million dollar
program that tracked it it was cut out
during the sequester
but i would be interested in knowing if
there's some other people
i don't believe it dan obviously
remember the waco ranch the bushes
if the moon wasn't out at night it was
pretty black there was no moonlight
coming down that sky could get pretty
black and you see some crazy stuff of
that you're like what is that thing out
there but yeah greg's right everyone
says they're gonna give us the big ufo
file this thing doesn't know ufo [ __ ]
yeah also i don't know that our
government knows
listen the government is a father bob
cerrico the acting institute had the
greatest line everyone they said it's
not that government's too big it's too
stupid
they can't keep a secret you think i'm
not suggesting there may be
ufos or may not be i'm just telling you
you think the government's keeping this
secret
how did you two not know you guarded how
many presidents you work for
people when i get out of the secret
service people swore to me
you saw the reels of brutal film you
know who killed jeff
that's the film man i'm not lying to you
i've left you were in the white house
but everything yeah this year the the
air force
the navy report is seeing something uh
right alongside it was a fly no it
wasn't real
that's what they want you to think and
also
another unit saw something over arizona
so
there's something out there we just
don't know i think bernie though is
out there enough that if there was a ufo
file and god forbid he was
could be a space alien i don't think
people need i will show you the file
you can do that you like that